doing the okay hand gesture is not okay
Blizzard was right to ban it and I'll
explain why
over the weekend Blizzard made headlines
for reportedly banning fans and
overwatch league events from making the
okay hand gesture after one fan throwing
up during an interview with LA
gladiators DPS players decay and guess
what Blizzard was right - man I know
what you're thinking
it's just a harmless hand signs and
yatta doesn't one of his wind poses it's
a spray in the game it's nothing the
problem is is that it might seem
innocuous but it's been co-opted by
people with ties to white supremacist
movements and I know some of you are
already in the comments telling you that
it's not a white supremacist symbol it's
all just a meme and I'm an idiot
but listen calm down I was like you a
week ago and then I did some research
and found out what's really going on
here a group of people on 4chan decided
to troll people by flooding twitter with
claims that the hand gesture was
actually a white power sign as part of
something they called Operation ok-kk
now this wasn't true at the time and was
just intended to mess with people the
problem is like with all memes it got
completely out of control what's [ __ ]
up is that actual white supremacists
have decided they like using the hand
sign it got so bad that the
anti-defamation league has stated that
while the okay hand gesture isn't
exactly a racist hand signal it has been
used by some white supremacists now the
ADL also says that context is super
important like if I said it that's okay
and then did this you know that I mean
that's okay and I'm not being a racist
the problem is when you try to hide the
gesture we've seen plenty of times in
history the people who want to keep
their beliefs and opinions hidden take
up coded language or symbols to hide it
from everyone white supremacists have a
[ __ ] ton of these and it's looking
like the okay hand symbol is becoming
one of these and if you're still
doubting me that guy who killed 50
people at two mosques in New Zealand
last month flash the OK hand gesture
during his arraignment in court
basically it's gotten pretty clear that
this while it seems innocuous has been
adopted as a white supremacist symbol
even if people aren't necessarily aware
of that okay that was a lot of fact so
let's recap really quick that okay hand
gesture started as a meme wasn't really
white supremacists then actual white
supremacist took it over and that's why
that overwatch league fan the guy who
actually flashed that hand Jess
the background didn't do anything wrong
he didn't know and actually he tweeted
an apology afterwards when he learned
the context that it's taken on but
people were mad that Blizzard made the
ban and I guess it's kind of
understandable it feels to them like
they're losing their free speech but I
don't actually think that's what's
happening here
and listen I get it it sucks seeing a
thing you like get turned into something
racist you're gonna fight back against
it but it's not about free speech it's
about not wanting to be associated with
racist ideologies the fact the matter is
blizzard gets to say what goes in their
studio they are not shredding on your
right to free speech and even if they
were you can go a couple years without
doing the okay hand gesture at least
until all this blows over and racists
lose the fight because history has shown
that they will lose and you'll get to do
your dumb hand gesture again Blizzard
has done this before they ban Pepe memes
from the overwatch League a few months
ago because it was an innocuous meme
that took on racist undertones and it's
not okay to use anymore look let's be
real here the okay hand gesture is a
[ __ ] white supremacist thing now
don't be mad at Blizzard for banning it
be mad at white supremacists for taking
an innocent thing and ruining it or you
know be mad at me for telling you all
this or whatever Blizzard is even
protecting some of their younger fans
from falling down the slippery slope of
racist memes whether they intend to be
racist or not
Blizzard got it right don't be mad at
than be mad at white supremacist for
turning something innocent into
something disgusting Pepe was associated
with racist memes so is the okay hand
gesture I don't want to see racism
anywhere in eSports and I don't think
you do either
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]